you are I mean think about it he worked
with everybody yes jay-z Beyonce Drake
Justin Bieber Rihanna I mean the list
goes on and on and on and you made us
yes you've eight you've incredibly
successful I think your most genius move
is that in all of these songs you yell
out your name at the time Jai Kali and
you gotta have the echo - wait can you
give me just give it to me one more time
go dj khaled yeah I love that I want to
play that throughout your interview
that's what I want to do can I hear it
back right now
DJ that should play throughout your life
when you're in a restaurant ordering
that should come up you know you're a
genius yes I am
yes I am yeah absolutely yes I am that
gotta be played all the time you know
the certain things I'm saying when I
make my hit records certain things have
to be there and that dj khaled has to be
there and that another one has to be
there and that we the best music have to
be there
those are like three major keys there
has to be in every single song and I
don't know almost yeah I'm angry that I
didn't think of it because I'm thinking
it would work in the talk show format if
I just routinely I'm talking to anyone
you know I'm talking to Fame Judi Dench
and I just go Conan O'Brien after after
he says Conan O'Brien let me get some
drums ready 1 2 3
Conan O'Brien so you see how it goes
you see how it goes like I said intro
intro and presentation is key yeah
saying like when you come out into your
show you got to hit him with the Conan
O'Brien another one can I say another
one and only if it's a hit record that's
gonna be a problem it's not going to
come up a lot
you